IT IS SUSPENDING COOPERATION
WITH THE U.S. ON A RANGE OF
ISSUES CRITICAL TO BOTH
COUNTRIES AND THE WORLD.
>> Reporter: A TORRENT OF
CHINESE AIRCRAFT, MISSILES AND
SHIPS MOVED TOWARD TAIWAN AS
SOON AS HOUSE SPEAKER NANCY
PELOSI LEFT THE ISLAND.
CHINA'S LEFT THE AREAS CIRCLING
WHERE ITS MILITARY IS DOING MORE
THAN JUST DRILLS.
TAIWAN SAYS 68 CHINESE WAR
PLANES FLEW AROUND THE TAIWAN
STRAIT FRIDAY.
CHINESE DRONES FLEW CLOSE TO
JAPAN, PROMPTING TOKYO TO
SCRAMBLE FIGHTER JETS.
EVEN AS IT CALLED FOR CALM, THE
WHITE HOUSE STEPPING UP ITS
RHETORIC.
SUMMONING CHINA'S AMBASSADOR TO
THE U.S. TO CONDEMN THE
PROVOCATIONS.
AN OFFICIAL WITH THE CHINESE
EMBASSY IN WASHINGTON TOLD THE
REPORTERS THAT THE ISSUE OF
TAIWAN IS SENSITIVE, SAYING
TAIWAN IS ONE OF THE VERY FEW
ISSUES THAT MIGHT TAKE CHINA AND
THE UNITED STATES TO CONFLICT OR
EVEN A WAR.
SO EXTRA CAUTION AND
RESPONSIBILITY ARE INDISPENSABLE
WHEN IT COMES TO TAIWAN.
BUT THE U.S. IS WORRIED THEY ARE
UNVEILING A YEAR-LONG CAMPAIGN,
CONSTANT PRESSURE ON TAIWAN,
AIMED AT A TAKEOVER.
>> THE SIGNIFICANT ESCALATION
AND THE LONGSTANDING ATTEMPT TO
CHANGE THE STATUS QUO.
>> Reporter: IN BEIJING, TOTAL
REJECTION OF THE U.S. POSITION.
>> Translator: IF THEY REALLY
WORRY ABOUT THE REGIONAL PEACE
AND STABILITY, WHY DIDN'T THEY
ACT EARLIER TO PREVENT PELOSI
FROM PAYING A PROVOCATIVE VISIT
TO TAIWAN?
>> Reporter: CHINA REACTING WITH
MEETINGS BETWEEN CHINESE AND
U.S. DEFENSE OFFICIALS.
PLUS IN CLIMATE TALKS WITH THE
UNITED STATES AND SANCTIONING
PELOSI AND HER IMMEDIATE FAMILY.
STILL, A MUTED U.S. MILITARY
RESPONSE IN THE REGION.
AN INTERCONTINENTAL BALLISTIC
MISSILE TEST POSTPONED OUT OF
CONCERN CHINA COULD MISINTERPRET
IT.
THE AIRCRAFT CARRIER RONALD
REAGAN EXPECTED TO RETURN TO
PORT IN JAPAN NEXT WEEK, AFTER
STAYING AT SEA FOR JUST A
HANDFUL OF EXTRA DAYS TO
MAINTAIN A U.S. PRESENCE NEAR
TAIWAN.
>> AND WE NOW HAVE THE FIRST
SUBSTANTIVE STATEMENT FROM THE
ACTING DOJ PRESS SECRETARY, AND
HE SAYS, I QUOTE, THE PRC HAS
CHOSEN TO OVERREACT AND USE THE
SPEAKER'S VISIT AS A PRETEXT TO
INCREASE PROVOCATIVE MILITARY
ACTIVITY IN AND AROUND THE
TAIWAN STRAIT.
PART OF THIS OVERREACTION HAS
BEEN STRICTLY LIMITING ITS
DEFENSE ENGAGEMENTS WHEN ANY
RESPONSIBLE STATE WOULD
RECOGNIZE THAT WE NEED THEM NOW
THE MOST.
ALTHOUGH THE PRC HAS
UNILATERALLY TURNED OFF A NUMBER
OF DEFENSE ENGAGEMENTS.
WE REMAIN OPEN TO COMMUNICATION
AND COMMITTING TO BUILD CRIS